you kind of give people like an idea
because i don't think a lot of people
understand like how an advance works and
i think all those artists who get it
it's a loan it's a loan it's a shitty
loan it's a loan very shitty it's
because if i if i finance a house for
you right you buy a house
after you pay it back you own the house
right mm-hmm even after you that money
is recouped that's the worst it's the
worst [ __ ] yeah so a loan a loan is like
a advance is just alone with like you
said shitty terms but a lot of times
these artists are in destitute and
impoverished situations so they're gonna
take anything and sign anything it's not
the labels fault per se it's a little
predatory it's predatory
it's predatory but that's why you're
supposed to have
a good lawyer or a manager yeah yeah i
think i can't i can't fault nobody for
falling for anything you signed because
you signed it there's layers between
like when megan like the whole megan
thing with uh carl crawford's going i'm
like yo you signed yes it's a deal
you're supposed to have management and
you're supposed to have a lawyer who
looks out for that if you failed those
two things you got to say you know what
i hired the wrong team and i signed the
wrong deal it was my fault it's the
label was going to do what the label
going gonna do they've been doing this
this is not nothing new you getting
tricked by antics that they they did
since the start of music this people was
complaining about deals and contracts in
the 1940s yeah so it's like you see this
but you decide to forgo that or you
don't have the right people to explain
it to you and you sign that deal and if
it's [ __ ] up you have to be a man or a
woman to say yo my team that i hired
or my team that was given to me that i
didn't investigate
allowed me to sign this and i [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up and i wanted to change
but don't say yo they took advantage of
me they gave you something that they
would give anybody and they also
i mean
you took the you took the bat like my
thing is yeah that's what i'm saying
like you know what when you was [ __ ]
up and you had a hundred dollars in your
pocket and they told they was gonna give
you events of seven hundred thousand you
was like give it to me i'm gonna sign it
you know what i'm saying that's like
people figure out the rest later it's
like people who have a bad attitude at a
store but like yo when you were at your
job interview i'm pretty sure you
weren't like this you were really happy
like what like the [ __ ] meek mill be
saying i'm like yo meek every time you
turn in an album
you know your advances in the seven
figures
so it's like you know what it is like it
i don't know what a meek mill album is
worth nowadays from the labels
perspective he's at least he's at least
getting uh at least
two to five million
every time
i also think though you can outperform
your contract i definitely feel like so
so if you outperform your contract they
like there should be some sort of clause
where i believe there should be almost
like almost like uh sports i believe the
contract ain't up yet but we need to
renegotiate let's let's keep it fair
tyler murray right now yeah let's
calamari let's let's keep it fair
because some of these artists they sign
these deals when they're when they're
young when they're unknown they're
unknown they're in a [ __ ] up situation
give me the bag then like who said it's
predatory of the label
they might make this label hundreds of
millions of dollars y'all could say you
know what
we got to switch this up
let's adjust this let's be fair but
there's nobody to hold the music people
accountable for that like it's just yeah
there's a very few people who do that
kind of show i feel like ships is the
kind of guy who will do that shapes is
like yo you know what
we need to fix this up you know what i'm
saying i'm very artist friendly let's
let's fix this deal up you know what i'm
saying no in terms of like you want
people to stay with you too yeah you and
you want to be you just want to be a
good human being a fair person like yo
listen i'm all for getting money i love
getting money getting money it gives you
freedom to do the things you need to do
but you don't want to take nothing from
nobody else out of somebody else's
pocket i'm saying like let that person
get what they earned and what's fair to
themselves as well